hay que pensar un poco en por qué las
permutas de incumplimiento crediticio
son comúnmente referidas a armas
financieras de destrucción masiva aquí
en el centro en el centro bueno no sólo
hay un vendedor de permutas de
incumplimiento crediticio pero voy a
poner un medio porque muchas de ellas
venden muchas muchas permutas de
incumplimiento crediticio ahige por
ejemplo es la más famosa pero tienes
aquí a un vendedor al que se le dio una
muy buena calificación esa calificación
se la dio una agencia de calificación
crediticia y quizás después la agencia
no le quiso bajar la calificación dado a
que dado a todas las preguntas de
incumplimiento crediticio que vendió
entonces agencia de de calificación
crediticia y bueno como puedes ver yo
aquí veo a estos dos cuates como los
principales culpables y quizás un poco
de las agencias regulatorias diciendo
hey mira estos dos cuates se están
vendiendo seguros quizás convenga a
regularlos pero con todo esto dicho tú
tienes a esta compañía
voy a poner aquí a las compañías en
círculos color rosa y estas compañías
quizás quieren pedir dinero de otras
entonces digamos inversionistas lo saben
color naranja
entonces los inversionistas les prestan
dinero a las compañías les da de interés
entonces da dinero de interés da dinero
de interés y luego los inversionistas
dicen hey acá hay un cuate con
calificación doble a las compañías a las
que les estamos prestando no tienen
doble a quizás ésta tenga por ejemplo
una vez esta una w
quizás esta otra tenga solamente una a y
entonces dicen yo quiero estar
totalmente seguro aquí por lo tanto le
voy a pagar a una prima y geo a
cualquier vendedor que tengamos quien
sea quién es y en cambio yo obtengo
seguro yo obtengo seguro en esta deuda y
así se van él le paga ahí y ahí se le da
en cambio seguro entonces aquí voy a
poner ahí que le da aseguró a los
inversionistas y parece bastante
razonable menos por el hecho de que a
este jugador aquí no guardo dinero o al
menos no la cantidad apropiada para
llevar a cabo la obligación de todas
estas compañías todo este riesgo que se
está tomando y claro todos estos riesgos
están correlacionados tú podrías
imaginar una situación en la que la
economía falla por
y um de repente esta compañía de aquí va
a fallar en los cumplimientos de pago y
también esta otra cuando la economía va
bien es probable que muy pocas de estas
compañías van a fallar y si la economía
va mal es probable que cualquiera de
ellas falle pero el verdadero problema
es en cuanto a estas compañías se
empiecen a fallar
entonces el vendedor de permutas de
incumplimiento crediticio tendrá que
empezar a pagar por las faltas de las
compañías tendrá que pagarle a los
inversionistas así que esta situación
puede llevar a la compañía aeg a la
quiebra y um de repente un de repente la
gente que creía tener seguro ya no tiene
seguro y entonces quizás las compañías
digan a espera yo sólo puedo tener deuda
doble y entonces le tiran esa deuda al
mercado o aún peor tal vez tienes a
estas personas aquí por ejemplo está
esta otra que no quiero empezar dinero
sin embargo ellos tal vez quieran hacer
apuestas paralelas en el estado de
economía diciendo hey yo yo creo que
esta compañía de aquí va a fallar con su
pago de deuda y ellos también pueden
obtener permutas de incumplimiento
crediticio
apuestas paralelas entonces quizás por
ejemplo esta compañía tenga un billón de
dólares en deuda y quizás todos estos
cuates apostaron por por la falta de esa
otra compañía así que quizás aquí sólo
hay un billón en deuda pero puede haber
cuatro o cinco o diez billones valor en
aseguranza en esa apuesta por un billón
así que si de repente esta compañía no
puede pagar su deuda de un billón
entonces ahora ahige no sólo está en
línea por ese billón sino ahora por 45 o
10 millones lo que hay ahí que ha
asegurado entonces le permite asegurar a
personas que no tienen un compromiso una
obligación con aquella compañía así que
imagina tal vez este cuate falla y pues
lo toman como perdido y ya pero quizás
algunos de estos jugadores tenían una
compensación de cobertura y por eso
quizás fue la razón que quisieron hacer
más que quisieron más compromisos antes
tal vez dijeron si la economía va mal yo
tengo aquí este seguro e hicieron una
transacción con otra persona y bueno si
la economía va mal um de repente ellos
dicen caracoles estoy en problemas pero
qué bueno que tengo está esta permuta de
incumplimiento
pero resulta que no la tienen porque hay
que fallo y por lo tanto este cuate se
vuelve insolvente así que adiós cuate
pero recordemos que este otro cuate
dependía del cuate vio que tenía
compensación de cobertura y le entró
pero ahora quizás él también sea
insolvente y podemos tener toda esta
cascada por todo el sistema financiero